the only common oxide of zinc has a
formula zn o zinc and then you have your
oxygen
write the electron configuration for a
zinc atom in the grounds state
so there's a couple of ways that you
could do this for the electron
configuration let's first identify zinc
on our periodic table of elements and
this is the actual one that they will
give you when you take the ap test and
so we have zinc right over here
zinc right over there and there's a
couple of ways you could do it the
simplest way is starting with the the
the no the
the no the noble gas that is before zinc
so that would be argon right over here
so you could say it's going to have the
same electron configuration as
argon
argon let me
so you're going to have argon but then
you're going to go and you're going to
add the four you're going to add
electrons to the 4s subshell so you have
4s1 4s2 so argon and then you have 4
s2
and then you go and
it's it's an oversimplification what i'm
about to say but when you're figuring
out electron configurations it's helpful
to think of well after you figure out
fill in the s shell subshell then you go
and backfill the 3d subshell so 3d1 3d2
3d3 3d4 5 6 7 8 9 10. so 4 s 2
3
d
3 d 10. and there's two exceptions in
this fourth row here you have the
exceptions of chromium and copper that
don't exactly fill just like that you
can look those up on your own but that
right over here is the electron
configuration for z for a zinc atom in
the ground state now another way you
could write this is actually writing out
the electron configuration for argon and
then writing 4s2 3d10 and well just for
the sake of it let's let's do that
so
you fill up your 1s2
so
we go 1
s2
and then we're in the second row so
you're going to have 2s2 and then 2 1 2
3 4 5 6 2 p 6 2 s 2 2 p 6
so let me write that down
2
s 2
2
p 6
and then you're going to go to the third
row so you're going to have and if this
looks completely foreign to you i
encourage you to watch the khan academy
videos on electron configuration and
then you're going to have 3
s 2
three p six you're going to fill those
two sub shells next three s two
three
p
six
and then what we've just described is
essentially the electron configuration
of argon and so then you get to four s
two and 3d10
4 s 2 and 3
d
3
d 10. so either of those would do
and then
the second part
from which sub-level are electrons
removed when a zinc atom in the ground
state is oxidized and this is what's
interesting about d block elements and
that's why i said it's a little bit more
nuanced than saying
you're kind of constructing this
electron by electron and you fill these
in the 4s2 and then you go and backfill
the 3d
because it actually turns out when you
have a neutral zinc atom the highest
energy electrons the ones that are the
most likely to be pulled away from that
zinc atom are not the the d electrons
it's actually going to be the four s two
electrons
so
the
which from which sublevel are electrons
removed well it's going or the the most
likely move not the force dude it could
be four s electrons so
the 4
s
4 s
sublevel and once again i encourage you
to kind of read more about that if
you're curious about why that is you can
kind of imagine in your head even when
you look at energy levels the 3d sub
level and 4s are very very very close
but it does turn out that most of the
time what's going to react are the ones
that are that are furthest out the 4s
ones so you could argue that those are
at the highest energy level and so when
you oxidize you start pulling electrons
off of zinc you can pull off the 4s you
can pull off you're more likely to pull
off the 4s electrons you're going to
pull off the 4s electrons